Uh, my name is Ela.
With me is Kevin. We're both principal
engineers working on Elasticash,
and in a minute, Kevin is going to walk us through
some code,
building a video sampling and search application.
But first I'd like to dive
a little bit into
how uh uh vectors similarity
search works with ValLKI.
So, uh, VSS works
on two data types with VALKy
on hash maps and on JSON
documents,
and you start by defining,
um, an index and defining schema.
And whenever you go and change,
uh, one of these objects,
that change
immediately happens on the main key database,
and then the search model
receives a keynote space notification.
And start asynchronously
indexing those uh those changes
using a set of uh dedicated
worker threads.
Now that means that the Valky main
thread
can continue serving other requests by other
users.
But that particular user that
sent the the the the the modification,
that waits, that user waits
because we have a synchronous
API
and a synchronous API is really, really useful
here because you can read your own rights,
right, versus other databases where it's
asynchronous, it will happen
sometime in the future.
So, once indexing complete,
uh, the, the user will get uh
an OK response and can continue.
Now queries
get handled immediately by
the query engine.
Those uh
the the work also happens on
dedicated worker threads.
So the queries get sent both to local indices,
but also to remote charts.
And that's because
when we search for nearest neighbors,
we don't necessarily know
at which chart the nearest neighbors are going to be.
So we fan out
and
the the query gets applied everywhere.
When the results come in,
optionally,
Valy will actually enrich them back
with data from the main database
and and send them of course back to the user.
Let's talk a bit about scaling
because it's a little bit different than
what you're used to with VALKy, if you're a VALy
user. So,
um, when you ingest
information, you send modification
to a particular primary in a particular shard.
That primary does the work of ingesting
and building, uh updating the index
and as synchronously
updates the replica, which also indexes the
information. Now,
this architecture means
that the more shards you add, like the,
the bigger you scale out,
the more data you can store.
And also it increases your ingestion
rate. So you can just billions
and billions of items
per second.
Well, maybe not billions per second, but,
uh, sport is very high,
the more you increase the shards.
Uh, search works differently.
When you send out the query,
the node that you send to has to fan out
to all the shards
like we
uh just mentioned.
And that means
that
as you as you add more shards,
it doesn't increase your throughput,
it doesn't increase your queries per second,
right, because all the work has to be done
by all the shards.
So what can you do if you need more
uh throughput, more queries per second?
You can add more replicas,
right, because as you can see.
Uh, decrease fan out to all the shards,
but they pick either a replica or
primary. So if you have a lot of replicas,
you can actually do more work concurrently.
Another good option is to scale up the
instance type,
right? If you have
more cores,
those dedicated worker threads can actually
do more work
and those actually are very, very efficient
at utilizing as a course.
Uh, let's talk about what Kevin is going to
build. So we'll
have a web application. It's going to
have two parts.
It's going to have an ingestion
part, which is where we upload
videos,
and it's going to have a query part
where we can query by either
text or image.
Now
what holds them together is actually Valy,
right? When we ingest,
we take images, we analyze them,
we turn them into embeddings using foundation
models,
right? So basically embeddings are vectors.
We insert
and when we query,
we take the query, it could be either a text
or an image,
right? We turn that also into an embedding,
transformed to vector using a foundation model,
and then we look for similar ones,
similar vectors or similar images
in bulky.
When we find something, we can
go and grab it off S3,
display to the user.
So the ingestion pipelines means that
we
take the video, we break it apart to
frames.
And
then we perform deduplication.
After we found images that are unique
enough, we run through multimodal analysis.
Diving deeper into the duplicate deduplication
and what it means on the application that
Tegain is going to build, it's going to be triggered
from an S3
insertion,
creation of object.
Then we're going to take the image, transform it
into an embedding, and we'll start
by looking
for similar,
similar images on Elasticash
on bulky.
If we find something that's similar
enough, like neighbors that are
close enough,
then that, that uh that image
is probably not unique enough, doesn't add
additional value or additional content,
right? So we can just throw it away,
we can save all the extra
analysis,
but if it's unique enough,
we'll continue our pipeline
and we'll run uh additional analysis
and eventually store it.
Now, the multi-modal analysis is
going to work by taking our image and
we're going to uh run it through, uh,
several, several, uh, analysis
models, right? We're going to use
uh categorization,
libelization, and summarization.
And we're going to take the output of all of these,
that's basically text, right?
That's the output. We're taking text
and we're taking the image,
we're putting them all into the foundation
model because we want to generate what?
Embeddings, right. That's what we're doing, right?
Embedding vectors. This is what
uh it's all about.
And then we're taking the text
transforming into embeddings, but we're also
inserting the text itself
along with the generated embeddings
into elastic cash. So,
you'll have this JSON
object that contains multiple
fields, right? It will have text
for all the things that we analyzed, and it will
have the vectors
that we that we got from the foundation
model, and then we'll we'll be
able to search for all of it.
Now, searching means
that the user is going to input either
text
or an image.
Uh, either way, we take that, we
also transform it into embedding
and we look for nearest neighbors.
Found something,
grab it off a tree,
display it.
Cool. So, uh, let me hand it over
to Kevin.
Yeah, thank you, lad.
Switch over to my demo machine.
So we'll start out by
just showing you what uh the completed
application looks like before we actually go in and, and, and
write some code here. So this is
the web UI that Ala was talking
about and I have one video here
that's ingested,
uh, which is an AWS ad,
uh, and what the system does, I can show you what if
I were to click into it.
It does all of the analysis on
these frames and provides some insights
into the video,
uh, including different labels that are,
uh, identified from, uh, recognition,
text from, uh, from
transcribe and, and, uh,
other things that are,
uh, identified through,
uh, the individual frames.
This is all derived from a set of frames.
So this is set at a 1 2nd
sampling,
yeah. On
the insights, yeah.
category.
That's OK. I can, I can
repeat it too, but.
Yeah, so I,
yeah, uh, on the
insights,
how do you
determine the label
category,
label,
and text,
please. Yeah, so these
are from the, uh,
the, the services that uh
that uh a lot talked about. So we feed
individual frames
to, uh, for example, like recognition
can identify labels. So let's say home and
indoors. Uh, so this may
not be the best, but so I see, uh, uh, hits
on, on, uh, home and indoors on frame
at the one interval, the 8, 18, and
27. I may, I can click through to those
and actually seek to those frames,
um, and see what,
uh, it doesn't tell me what is identified,
but these are just some of the machine learning services
that AOS provides,
taking, taking in, in, uh, the images input.
So these frames are, uh, I can
go in and see the, uh, the extraction
of the frames and so it goes,
uh, frame by frame here, uh,
in, in a one second sampling interval.
Each of these frames is then fed to Claude
in this, uh, uh, demo
to generate a summary,
uh, and these are, you can see the label, another view of seeing
labels and,
uh, text as well as subtitles
for each of them.
Uh, that
as it goes and you see it's 1 2nd intervals,
but there's also a similarity score here
that, uh, it can be observed,
uh, and this is derived from the deduplication
process, uh, and so we can see that,
uh, these frames are, I think we have a set a
threshold of 0.24,
uh, frames that are below that will be dropped
because they are
similar enough to another frame.
And so all of this, uh, is the, the
information that is, uh, derived
from those individual frames.
So let me walk through the, the pieces
of where Valy fits into this. That's
what we'll be, uh, uh, walking
through today.
And to start out with, I wanted to start
by clearing out
the code that is already written,
uh, and to do that, I'm just gonna do a quick
CDK deploy,
uh, to.
Remove
The information on here and
so this is all a uh
driven by uh a CDK package.
That should clear things out. Uh,
let me go over here.
From the lambdas that we're gonna be implementing
with and I'm also gonna delete this video.
We'll clear everything out.
So the, the actual frames are stored in S3
metadata, in this case, durable metadata
stored in Dynamo DB
and then the vectors themselves are
stored inside VALKy. So I'm
gonna pull up a, a, a VALKy CLI
here and clear out all of the
information that's in VALKy just so we start out fresh.
Uh, my VALKy, I can show you first.
Here, so, uh, Elastic Ash
has a number of different configurations, and this one
we're using, uh, a,
uh, provisioned, uh, Valky cluster
running, uh, version 8.2,
which is, uh, uh, the version that supports vector
search.
Uh, I'm, I have 3 shards, each of
which has,
uh, 3 replicas, so it has 9 nodes
total. In my cluster
and they're running on a
R7,
where does it show the R7GX
large node type,
uh, but it's supported on a variety of different
instance types that you can configure.
Uh, so I'm going to
do this.
There's 3 different shards. I will flush
all on all of them.
And I'm just doing this by uh
using get to move
to the different shards here.
Uh, if you don't, aren't familiar with Valy, I'm
just basically, uh, flushing
everything out. Uh, the indexes are defined
a little bit differently, so I'm
going to, um,
call drop index.
So, let me do this.
And this will start over from scratch, so we have
a clean slate to
build off of.
Cool. So now,
the first thing we need to do in that uh
is to get in that um
pipeline that we talked about is getting d-duping working
and, and storage.
Uh, and so all of this is derived from
all the embeddings that we're using today are, are, are
derived from Amazon Titan.
So we're using two different embedding models.
One is the, the V2 for
text,
which is slightly better on, uh, text information.
And then we're using this multimodal embedding
model and that can generate embeddings
on both text and
on images so we can feed in those frames
and get back vectors,
uh, so we're gonna be, uh, implementing
that through
Bedrock. Let me go ahead and refresh these.
Any questions
so far?
Cool. OK.
So,
uh, I can walk through this
lambda. So this is, uh, this application
is, uh, broken up into a bunch of different
lambdas, each of which are purpose-built.
A lot of them are connected via, uh,
step functions which we can, we can look at in
a little bit.
So, one of the, uh, the core ones
is actually the, the function to generate embedding is
because we use that everywhere on search, we use that on,
um, ingestion, we use that on deduplication.
So, right now, uh, the lambda
doesn't do, uh, that much. Let me
see.
If I can get it to
It shouldn't be doing much.
Let's see what my CDK deploy
did.
Uh, it did work.
Let's go ahead and reopen
it, make sure it's not cached.
Let's see what this does.
Uh
Moss modified 6 hours ago.
Worst case I can clear it out myself.
If it isn't going to get updated
by the
deployment here.
One second.
Um,
Was it a regional issue?
Let's see.
The embedding one here, I'll just start
um. 1
2nd.
I flushed out all the data but not all of
the code.
OK, that's not wanting to.
Delete
So
I will
push it.
Manually.
Cool. Copy
and paste.
OK.
From my local to here,
deploy.
We'll see if that happens on the other ones too.
So the empty one is uh actually
empty here
now,
and it is a lambda handler
that, uh, does some validation and
currently just returns,
uh, nothing in it's, uh, response
here.
Uh, but what it's supposed to do is take the,
uh, text and image input,
both of which are optional, and then the embedding
type to call one of the models
or the other.
Uh, so, the first thing we wanna do, uh,
is to, uh, and, and create
Bedrock. Uh, it's, I got some help
here with from Amazon Que,
uh, but I'm just gonna do a, use the
Boto 3 clients. This is Python,
and, uh, connect to the Bedrock runtime.
And
we'll do, uh,
the autocomplete is nice here.
Um.
And if you see any typos, feel free
to call them out too as I'm doing this.
You'll, you, we can do some uh peer, uh, pair
programming,
uh, in this so that it actually works.
So, uh, we want to do,
uh, the different embedding models here. So
if the embedding model is, uh, that's correct,
MM then we wanna do the multimodal embedding
type,
um, else we'll do the text
model.
This is a little bit helpful.
And then we want to generate our
request, which is going to be a JSON.
Uh, we could do that or we
can do simpler just a text input
then do.
So if we want to look up the API, I don't have
it here for Bedrock, um, but
it takes in a JSON document and
it takes an input.
Or
uh if there's image.
Input then we'll do.
The image
And if you haven't worked with Bedrock before,
it's pretty easy to do it. In fact,
you can autocomplete it for me.
Uh, we will,
uh, dump the request as a JSON
document.
We'll call the correct model.
I don't even need necessarily the accept and the, the
content type, but
this will then return the vector
response to.
So I can get the body out of the, uh,
response by loading
the,
uh, response body here.
And
then
uh get the embedding out of it. So it's uh
a JSON with a, a, a single field here
that is get embedding or
called embedding.
And I'm just gonna return that
in the body here. I could return the actual JSON
blob, but I'm returning the vector embedding.
OK. I
think that looks all right. Let's see. So we'll go ahead and deploy
it and test it.
Is anyone spotting any obvious mistakes
in here?
This is just demonstrating that it's
pretty easy to interact with
uh bedrock.
So I'm going to just create
a simple test here. I need my embedding
type and text image.
Let's do that.
Create a tested via embedding type is
text,
and it was what? Text image,
no text
input image.
Text input
Input of Hello World
and what I'm expecting to get back.
Is a.
A vector,
which I do,
uh, get a large vector, it's a
1,024,
uh, in
vec in length, which we can find out
just from the output vector size here.
Now So
this is, oh, you what is
generating the vector is the question.
Uh, so yeah, the question is, is, uh,
the lambda the one generating the vector.
In this case,
the lambda is not doing the vector. The lambda is just, uh,
basically just calling the bedrock service,
and the bedrock service is the one that is,
um, interacting with the,
uh, the Titan model. There are local. Embedding models,
so you, the, the it is an option to generate
embeddings
within the lambda or an EC2 instance locally
here, uh, for, for this demo
we are just interacting with Bedrock
via the IOCLI
and it's getting the credentials just locally
through the, uh, through the lambda in order to
invoke, uh, that remote service
to get the embedding.
I Yeah, the question is, do
you need, uh, a token ID or or credentials,
and that is true. It's, uh, this is
set up so that, uh, the land uh has,
uh, the, the, the, the credentials
present and so the default SDK
picks it up just by instantiating
the, the client.
So this is the foundational one. It looks like it's
working, uh, but it's not gonna
do anything if we were to ingest a video because
we haven't hooked it up to ValLKy yet. And so the
next step is to go ahead
and, uh, uh, take
it when it, uh, has a vector
and has, uh, uh, decimated
the video to actually
store that information
inside Valy.
And in that we have this vector
save
functionality, which again has not, has not
been cleared out, it looks like. So I
can do my same
trick I did before of
taking the empty one
locally and overwriting
it.
And deploying it.
Cool. So, this one,
is later on in the,
uh, in the path where it has already, uh, taken,
has a keyframe
and all this information stored
inside, uh, Dynamo DB and it's
provided in this, uh, event context
that we have,
uh, the S3 image, we have
some task ID, we have the frame.
And some configuration items. So this
frame, uh,
is the, the JSON blob that
we're going to store inside
Elastic cash,
and it has a bunch of fields I can show you before. It
has things like, you know, the, the S3 URI
to be able to display in the UI
timestamp,
a, a lot of the metadata necessary to,
uh, perform the vector search as well as the actual
vectors, uh, themselves.
So those are already populated here.
Uh, so our job here is to, um, initialize
it. So we have create ValLKYClient,
which is not doing anything, um, right now,
uh, and so we want to be able to connect it into,
uh, ValLKy.
So to do that, we're going to use a client that's
called Valky Glide.
Which is one that our team
supports.
Uh, it is uh one of the official, uh,
clients for VALCI,
and it is a polyglot client, so it supports
multiple different languages.
We're going to be using the, the Python
one here since all of our lambdas are
in Python.
So, I'm going to import um
some things here and I'll see
if you can figure that out.
Probably not
from Glide sync.
I'm just importing star here since there's a bunch of different
ones that we're gonna be using for this.
Uh, so, actually, let's do
just the glide synca is sufficient
to be able to create the client.
So to initialize the client, we have
a, uh, domain endpoint
and a port.
So those are sourced just from our
Elastic Ashwan. We have a single configuration endpoint
and port here. So, uh, there's a
DNS name and a port 6379
that we're using in order to connect to our
cluster.
And the way that VALK works in cluster
mode is it, it, it discovers all of
the different nodes. We talked about there being 9 nodes
in our in our cluster. So it,
uh, from this configuration and point it queries
any node and is able to identify
which, uh, what the 9 nodes are and
uh talk to them for pieces of data. So it's a
direct communication from the client
into the,
uh, the nodes that have all of this data resident
in memory.
So, let's go ahead and
uh initialize our client.
Uh, so we'll do that, we'll do return, uh,
our glide cluster client. We're using the cluster
client because it is, uh, cluster
mode enabled,
uh, create.
And we'll pass it some cluster
client configuration.
Configuration.
Pass it the list of addresses. In
this case, we just have one address, which is
the, uh, domain endpoint,
and then we will, uh,
pass it to the port.
You see port.
In this case, we have enabled TLS,
uh, but not authentication. So if we look
under here, we have encryption and transit
enabled,
uh, and so that is an option that you're able
to, to toggle,
uh, but we don't have any
authentication which is also available,
but it'll make it a little bit easier. So with,
uh, just TLS we can set the use
TLS flag to be true and then the client will
do the TLS negotiation.
And we're going to set some configuration
here, uh, to, uh,
increase our time out here,
advanced, uh, glide client configuration.
And we're gonna set a, uh, 2-second timeout
here, which works best for this particular
demo.
So that should work to uh actually create
the client.
And to actually, we'll, next we'll, we'll skip
the index creation because that uh can happen
async here and we wanna be able to store
this frame. So the, the fundamental data
structure that we're working with here is the JSON
one inside uh Valy.
So that is uh one of the
uh modules that is available.
For, uh, for,
for Valky
that comes, comes with the, the bundle there
and
Glide supports it using this uh glide,
uh, JSON wrapper. So we're gonna have to import
that first,
uh,
and then we can use it. So from Glide sync,
we'll import, actually, uh,
actually I think it's there by default, it's the full text that
we don't have there.
Glidejson. uh set. And we'll pass at the
uh EC client.
At you can
slightly this
lambda function.
Uh, yeah, the question is, is there a way to,
uh, generate this code using an agentic
AI, and that is, that's a good question, and the answer
is yes. You see, Q is attempting
this here, but, uh, it,
it is not succeeding always.
Uh, I did play around with trying to do this
in, uh, using Quiro.
Uh, for, for this demo, and it, it,
it has a lot of background information on,
uh, you know, invoking Bedrock, a little bit less so
in it's,
uh, in its data set on,
uh, using,
uh, Valky Glide because that's a
little bit newer repo, but, uh,
I was able to get it to, to generate,
uh, the code there too. So that is an
option, uh, for you to use this
or anything else to, to try using,
um, a, uh,
a, a large language model to do this code generation.
It was the question is, is, uh,
Cairo is what?
Yeah. Uh, so,
oh, so not, it's, I'm not using it right here. Oh, so the one that's
being used here that's popping up, I think it's just Amazon
Que,
um, which I can, it's running, I could pause
it, but, uh, Que
is, uh, part of the lambda
console.
7 already
here. I
don't think that there's a, a code generator
within the lambda console.
I could be wrong on that.
Um,
uh, there is an Amazon Q tab
here, but I think it's just for asking
questions.
Uh, but you could use something like, uh, uh,
Quiro here that I have that allows you
to, um, to actually generate
code by, uh, chatting with it.
I'm not doing that today just to kind of illustrate
the, the actual points as opposed to
um having it generate something for us.
So, when I set the, uh, I'm passing on the client
and then I want to set it uh with a particular key
index. So everything in VALKy is indexed by
a key name,
and here I am putting a frame
uh as the prefix to the,
the frame and then the frame ID which is unique.
And that's a common pattern for interacting with,
uh, VALKy. And since this is working with
JSON, I'm gonna replace the entire JSON document,
um, so the, the dot, and
then I will dump the frame.
Uh, using JSON, and so this will take the,
take it and store it inside
Valy,
uh, and you can interact with JSON.
You don't need to have a vector index, that's just
one of the data structures that's supported, but here we want
to be actually able to create an index
so that when we do this set, it automatically ingests
it and makes it available for vector
search. And this is getting into now
some of the vector functionality, the VSS
capabilities
there. And so there's a lot of different options.
Uh, I will show the Valky command
for let's do FT create.
So Valki has a, uh, is pretty well documented,
um,
uh, in terms of what
the commands are, it's a little bit hard because it has
the command here on the side, but,
uh, so we have an FT create function. So
FT stands for full text, but,
uh, right now Valy supports just vector,
uh, search. Full text is coming soon.
Uh, and we can create a schema with a
bunch of different,
uh, field types and, and
attributes,
and so we'll do that just to index two
different vector fields, one of the text
and one of the, the image like we
had done, uh, talked about before. So let me
go back there.
So to actually create the index,
uh, we only have to create the index once and we could do this
manually, but we're gonna make it, uh, uh,
do it as part of the, the lambda.
So in order to do that, we can test to see if it
exists first.
Uh, I would need to actually import all
of my full text stuff, so that doesn't come in the glide
sync. Those are, uh, separate commands.
So from glide sync.
sync commands, we'll import FT
to interact with the,
the VSS module,
and then from
glide shared commands, server
modules is a little bit long.
This is where having,
uh,
Gen AI created would be helpful,
create options,
import star.
OK.
Uh, so now I should be able to call FT.info,
pass it to the
client,
and then check to see if our
index, we're gonna have one index here
if it, if it exists, uh, we'll call it the, the,
uh, index with the,
uh, video frames.
Uh, this will throw an exception if it doesn't
exist, except.
Exception is X. OK. And
so if it doesn't exist, then we'll go ahead and try and create
it here.
Uh, and so, to create it,
we have to create, um, a schema
first. And
so we have to define what exactly the fields are that
we want to index. So we'll
call, we'll say it's a vector field.
The name is gonna be where we find it in
the, well, we can
talk about uh where it's coming from
later, the data type, but within the JSON field,
it's gonna be called MM embedding for multimodal
embedding.
Uh, we'll alias this just to
MM embedding so we don't have to deal with the
dollar sign at the front. So when we actually query
it, we'll just have to, we'll,
we, we can drop the dollar sign.
We're gonna use the, uh, HNSW algorithm.
Oh, look, it is
helpfully.
Um
Doing it. Let's see if it's actually correct. It's a
little bit wrong. Vector vector
algorithm is the right one.
Uh,
so this is the, you know, the pitfalls of using
Gen AI
that it might get it mostly correct, but not 100%.
So, we'll do, uh, HNSW.
I'll go ahead and pause that so that it doesn't distract
from The
Let's see.
He was down at the bottom.
OK.
That should be a little bit better.
Uh, HNSW,
that did not work.
And we'll, we'll see if it works, uh, now,
uh, and we want to pass
at the attributes for HNSW. So HSW is,
um, uh, uh, the graph navigation
scheme,
and we have to pass at what the vector field,
uh, attributes are, what, what, how many dimensions
to expect, and, and sort of how we wanted to,
um, generate a score for that.
So, we, we can pass it and
tell it that there's 120, 1,024
dimensions in these vectors,
and we want to use the cosine metric
as opposed to, uh, the, the
metric L21. So, we'll do metric type.
cosine.
And we'll generate a, uh,
they're all float thirty-twos all of them in
the, the vector field.
So we can basically, uh, so this is the multimodal embedding,
we can kind of copy and paste this for the
text embedding because it is, uh.
Line 38 distance,
yep,
thank you.
Good eye.
We'll see
then if I'm able to copy and paste this
for the text embedding.
Uh, which is just in this text
embedding. OK, so this allows us to
index two different fields. Each of
there are different embeddings. One is just representing the
text and one is representing text and image.
Uh, so this is the, uh,
most of how we create the schema
here, and I just need to
finish, yeah, OK, defining
it. Uh, and then there's a couple
of options we need to tell it which fields to index. So but
we could look for everything that's stored into
Valy to try and index all, uh,
JSON, uh, uh, documents, but here we're just
gonna, uh, narrow it down
to,
uh, things that are JSON
and that start with this frame
prefix.
So we can, or we can say anything that
starts with frame,
uh, we'll, we'll inspect to see if
we can insert it into the
index, and this allows us to
store other things on the same balky server
without having to index them or to insert
them in different indexes.
Uh, and as a lot talked about earlier, we can have one,
object be in multiple indexes if we,
uh, so chose.
And then we can just do, I'm gonna do
a, uh, we could do FT.create
to create the thing,
um, pass it the video frame,
the index ID, and then schema and
options. So this will create the
index. Uh, I'm going to surround this
in a try catch just because,
uh, there might be a race here where we most,
um, several of them try and create at
the same time and one of them will throw an error.
So, uh, normally I
would handle this better, but.
Since we're just doing it for demo purposes, we'll
just ignore it errors that get thrown here
and validate manually.
So now we have the ability to
create the client.
We'll first try and see if the index
exists. If not, we'll go ahead and, and
create it,
and then we'll go ahead and store
this. We could do it the other way around. It's not
important to create the index before you store data.
Indexes are backfilled, so you can dynamically
drop them and recreate them, and it'll go and
search the, the key space and,
and reindex and everything as necessary,
uh, but this, uh, uh,
is the.
Uh, the way that we've chosen to do it here.
Uh, and if I got all of the,
no other typos, we'll go ahead and
try and deploy this.
There's another typo
Online 59 exception,
yeah.
Cool. I don't have a test for this, so I could
theoretically test it,
um, within the lambda, but I'd have to
generate the, uh,
the right context here, so we're just gonna,
uh, test this through the application.
And while that's running, I'm gonna go
ahead and clear out the one other lambda
function that we will uh be
creating since it didn't get cleared out before,
which is search, and I'll deploy an empty
version of that.
Yeah, I don't care. OK.
Deploy empty search.
OK,
now,
let's go ahead and.
Go back to our application and.
That's stuck and deleting.
That might be why things are not working very well,
OK. We're
going to ignore the ones stuck in deleting.
Uh, because we've already manually cleared out
everything within the elastic cache.
So, let's go ahead and check to see
if
this works. There should be nothing created
yet. Yeah, cool, and
there should be no, no keys.
OK, and,
um,
so this is a multi-shard cluster,
so the, the, the keys will be targeted at
specific nodes. Each frame might land
in a different shard.
However, the index only needs to be created once
in one shard and it automatically propagates
to the other shard, so everyone,
uh, gets that same index.
So let's go ahead and try and adjust the
video and see what happens.
Uh, uh, the, I'm going to ingest
the same
ad that we played with earlier.
And I got a bunch of settings here,
uh, and this allows you to, uh,
choose a sampling interval. Here we're just doing,
uh, one,
for every 1 2nd,
and this is what we talked about before for each image
frame we can run different detections here.
So recognition
picks up labels and text,
um, as well as the moderation and celebrities,
and then the summary is done from Haiku
and then Transcribe,
uh, does the subtitles.
Uh, so we're gonna just keep the defaults
here. And
upload it
And so then this runs a,
uh,
a step function which we'll go ahead and, and look
at in a moment that runs through the transcription
and then all of the different analysis.
Uh, so, as a lot talked about earlier,
the, um,
Valy is, is best for, for real-time use
cases that's ultra low latency. This isn't
really a good showcase of the real-time
capabilities because,
uh, this is done at a, a little bit lower
or is done sort of
in an offline fashion, right? We're, we're running
a workflow on this and then, um, showing
a web UI that can do searching. So,
uh, it's really just there as an, uh,
to show an example application of,
uh, how you would connect it, but.
Uh, the,
where Valy would shine is if you're doing sort of real-time streaming
analysis or other things
where, where the, uh, latency
and throughput are,
uh, much higher than in this example
application. Let's
go ahead and check on the.
Uh,
extraction flow here, so.
We're running through a, let's see if I can
make this bigger, yeah,
running through a set of lambda functions,
we'll get the video metadata,
uh, can I make this
maximize, yup.
And zoom in.
So we sam we go through the sampling and
uh removing redundant frames
through the sampled images to, to de-dupe them
and then we iterate through them,
extract
metadata and actually store those
uh vectors
and it looks like
something probably didn't work.
So let's go ahead and dig into
what else
went wrong here.
Vector is not defined. OK, so
either I made a, a typo in
the
save.
Where did I say vector?
Vector dot, uh, it's vector type.
There we go, let's try that.
Cool,
and we'll rerun.
From failure
See if it can complete successfully.
Um, still
not. Let's see if
if I made other typos.
Uh, create options doesn't have,
uh, the, the ait and the create
index. Let's go look at that.
Have to create options has.
A data type and
ah it's prefixes there
we go.
This is where I wish
Q would help me
if only I could ingest the Jasons
uh syntax here,
which I have the, uh,
this one.
OK, let's go ahead and try it one more time.
So this is iterating them, I think in a loop
with a fairly low concurrency,
so it takes a little bit longer again if you're doing something
real time, it could ingest it as the
the frames are being streamed in.
So that uh completed successfully
now after I fixed all those typers and we should
be able to see
on this non-deleting one the same UI that
we saw before
where we are, uh, see the, the different
image frames.
And I'll point out that there is one duplicate
here, so this particular image I just pulled
from, uh, from YouTube, but you see similarity
scores.
Uh, the frame 9
often has, yeah, so it goes from, um,
frame 8 here to frame
10,
and that's because if I were to look at
what happens between
8 and 9, it's sort of the same,
uh, woman moving around,
uh, before it gets to that
point and so I was able to de-dupe a
particular frame there.
So let's go ahead and look at what that looks like
inside uh Valy. So now if I
run key star, it may have keys, it
probably should because they're in different ones. So I see
frame, prefix, and then a
timestamp at the end.
So this is a UUID followed by the timestamp
here. I can do a
uh JO.get
on
um mine and this is.
Uh,
lots of vectors, but we see it has some
things other than vectors. It has task ID
and then it has the embeddings that we generated
two of them,
and then it has the actual metadata itself text,
uh, and labels. This is all the stuff
that it's actually indexing in the vector,
um, as well as then the, let
me see if I can make this bigger, uh,
I may not be able to readily.
Uh, oh, I can, there we go.
Uh, and then the S3 URI. So this is all,
um, the, what is being indexed.
If I list my,
um, vector indexes, I
have one that does the similarity checking,
and then this video frame index is the one that we defined
before, and I can run an FT info
to get information, observability about the
actual video frame.
This gives a lot of input, but it, it gives the definition.
We defined it with both the text
embedding and the multimodal
embedding.
Uh, but the interesting part is also tells us how many documents
have been indexed. So there's,
um, 7 different documents, 14
records
within that index that we can, uh, search
on this particular node which should correspond
to the number of
keys here, 7, yep,
so each node has a portion of that index
and so when search happens it fans out,
but that is transparent to
the application.
So if it was cleared out successfully, search
should be broken right now,
um. If I were
to try and do some semantic search
here,
it will return nothing, no videos
are found because it is not hooked up. So the last
part that we want to do is make this searchable
and to do that, we will look at the search,
um, function here.
Uh, so we've created the index, we've populated it, and
now we want to search it. So this is, uh,
taking the information from that web UI
when I do a search.
I've pre-populated it with a Valky connection,
but we just need to call, basically
implement a function to do searching
the text embedding.
We'll do that first, this the text, which is semantic
search. So we have the input text,
uh, and the, uh,
the score threshold which we'll use to
um find just uh relevant
results.
Uh, so to do this we do this, uh, an FT
search command.
Uh, and that one I will walk through here,
uh, kind of quickly. So, uh, to start with, we
just have the text as input. So the first thing we need to do
to generate is to generate the embedding
from the text, and this, uh, get
embedding function we'll call that lambda that we
defined earlier
and basically transform the input
text into, uh, a
vector embedding.
We'll pass it the input text but no image.
And then we need to query,
uh, the, the given vector and so to,
uh, index and to, to do that, we,
we will use the syntax that is defined
in
uh Valy command FT search.
It's a little bit of a, uh,
uh, a syntactically
difficult, um,
uh, query, but I can, I'll walk
through what it means. So, first, the star
means that we're not gonna do any filtering on the vectors. We,
we could filter by different tags. We're
not gonna get into that today.
We'll do a K nearest neighbor search
and we'll pass in a default
K, which is 20 in this example, but we
could just hard code the number here.
And we will query this text
embedding field
in the, in our one in our uh index,
and
we will then
use this to say our, uh,
we will
uh pass in our query vector
uh as a variable
and we will, uh, return the
actual score here.
Uh, we want more than just the score. By
default it'll just return the score, and that's
not very useful because we want some metadata out
of this rather than just the, the key name,
which is just a UUID. So we can do that
by doing vector search options.
And we'll return some different
fields that are also populated
in that JSON,
uh, so we'll do return field
field identifier equals,
so we want the score and then we went to other fields
too. So let me copy and paste
this.
We want, uh, the task ID
to be able to populate it. We want the.
Image S3 URI,
which is also in there.
We want the time stamp
and we want the text itself to
be able to display what the, the matching text
is. So
those are our fields that we're returning.
We're going to, uh, by default,
it returns just 1010
results no matter what the K is that you pass in, so
we want to be able to change that
and set it to return
20 in this case.
So we'll do.
EC default K.
And then lastly, we need to actually pass in the vector
that we're searching and to do that,
we will define this query vector
parameter that is, uh, matches
this string here.
And we'll put it, uh,
packet as a structure so that it can be,
um,
sent over the wire.
And so we'll encode it in a way that is.
Uh, recognizable by Valy.
Um,
we pack length of the embedding and
then.
Take the actual raw embedding itself.
OK.
I think that looks good for the query
and then we just need to call the.
The, the
function itself, so we'll do FT.search,
pass in the client,
the.
Uh, index name
that we're searching
and then the options that we just defined.
And then we have a helper function here that
will format those results
and do filtering and return it in
the way that we want it to be displayed in the UI.
So we'll do format frame results of the
response with our given score threshold.
So this will do some filtering.
OK,
and
this one's easier to test because we can just run the
web UI as soon as the deploy happens. Let's see
what if I made any mistakes
here. So
now if I were to do the same thing, search
AWS.
Aha I
did not memorize this well enough. OK,
let's go ahead and find the.
Uh, FT search options.
Um, can anyone find my
mistake? If
not, then we'll go into our.
Cloud watch logs and find it out.
What air is returning back.
Set has no items.
And this, did I
pass in the wrong.
Uh, query options. Do I pass in a
a set instead of a list?
Let's go back.
Where am I doing a set?
I have a return field list.
FD search.
Victor said.
Prams is, yes, that's
it.
Colon,
thank you. And this
still is correct, yep.
Let's try that.
Thank you. Cool,
so I get back 20 frames in the single
video.
I can expand this and see,
uh, it ordered from most, uh, relevant
to least relevant. So as you can see when we do a search,
it pulls out things that are, uh,
with the lowest score here, uh, that
actually represent AWS. So the,
the, uh, Claude was able to pull out,
uh, the AWS text from here
and if we look at some of these other ones we can see AWS
is in the, the image here at the bottom.
AWS is present here, so the most relevant
results are,
um,
uh, come up first.
We still haven't done the multimodal search,
though that is, uh, basically the
same thing, so we can
copy and paste
a lot of this except we're just going to
be searching,
uh, a different, and I could
come up with a helper function here, but I'm not
going to right now.
So, uh, we will search the
multimodal uh generate the multimodal embedding,
pass in the image as well,
change this to MM embedding.
I think that's
it. Um, we get the
same details out, it's just a separate embedding.
It's within the same index.
Let's see what that does.
And so now that opens up this
other drop down search where I can do a multimodal
search. This one I can pass in text or an image.
Uh, I'm going to search now for an ogre
because there is an ogre in this video or
a monster of some sort.
We can see if it shows up correctly. OK, we
still got 20 frames
and
the top ones are of this.
Monster that is uh in the AWS
one and I could do a combination
of that so I could, uh, you know, uh,
search, let's let's see if I search AWS
and
Ogre it, it sort of interleaves them
so because it's generating and embedding across both,
uh, simultaneously so I can see things that
are most relevant of the ogre and
of AWS.
Cool,
uh, and
I think that is everything that
I wanted to demonstrate
today. Uh, I wanted to talk, I
say that this is an application that is,
um, largely available online
in the AWS Solutions library.
Uh, the caveat being that this, uh, was originally
developed for OpenSearch, so
it doesn't work against Valy.
Uh, the, the, the code that is
running is against, um,
uh, OpenSearch, but you can swap
it out for,
uh, for Valy, but it is a. And
within AWS labs here you can
do it's called guidance for media extraction
and dynamic content policy framework.
So it's a framework you can walk through, uh, in
your own time as, uh,
if you wanna understand more about how,
uh, the entire ingestion pipeline works.
Uh, and with that, I wanted
to open it up to any questions that folks
have. Uh,
yes, so the services you ran.
Expensive they bully you,
um. You're putting it
straight in the balcon.
It makes sense to put it in the booking search and
store the the weddings.
Yeah, so the question is about cost like is this
a cost efficient way to to do.
But generally
Uh, yeah, so that is a good point. So,
uh, yeah,
the elastic cash, the, the information there
is ephemeral. So in this particular
case where you want, uh, something
long lasting, you're right, uh, I think
a, a durable database would be a better
fit for this
particular use case,
uh, which is why something that's real time where you're actually.
Doing like say security analysis or something
where the information is more ephemeral, you want to
look for
particular threats
and then you don't really care that you
age it out or set a TTL that would
be a better use case for
the vector search on elastic
elastic ash.
You support So
you can store you could store the embeddings in
something like Dynamo which doesn't
have a, a vector search capability and
then you could um do
the uh transition it into
Valy if it's just a uh you know, a core working
set so that you could have it be, uh,
easily searchable uh. Then age
things out. That is uh one way to do it. Like
we could set TTLs on all of these JSON
documents and have them be
removed after some period of time,
uh, and so it just but still, uh, mastered
in another durable database that,
that is, um, a pattern that
that we see customers use.
This question in the back.
Let's, yeah. Is it possible to get your
code the way that you implemented this
through GitHub? The content
of of the uh the Valy,
uh, for the Valky,
uh, it, it, it's not currently available.
I think we could look into making the, the Valky,
um, parts itself, um,
available if you wanna come. I, I can chat
with you afterwards and, and, uh, work, work,
work with you to get, get the information to you.
Thank you. Another
question over here in the.
question, but I'm
I'm like generally confused about um.
Using embedding caches because
you're gonna get cash hits all the time.
Um, and then you won't end
up searching your durable storage.
So in this case we're using uh Elasticash
as our uh our our primary
vector database. So in, in this case, uh
there is no other vector database in the picture.
We've replaced OpenSearch or, you know,
post uh
Postress with uh Elastic Cash
entirely.
So you will get cash hits anytime,
uh, there is a a relevant.
Match
is the question about how you would use Elastic cash
as a vector database in front of like another vector database that's
your durable store.
Yeah, so you could do that as well, right? You can do a cert
in this case we could just have, oh, you know, a
hot working set here, uh, but it
would require us to, you know, if
there's a miss we might need to fall back
to the database. So it, it would front.
Um,
the, the, uh, cash hits
but not necessarily cash misses where
you would then, uh, need to go fall back and
perhaps bring that vector into,
um, the, uh, Valy
so you could do a similar pattern as like a look aside
cash
without vectors. Uh, you would just have
that two layer cash for for the vector
search, but there could be like a much.
Close, uh, more similar vector in your durable
storage that you just wouldn't hit because there's
something in your cash.
Yeah, so it, it depends on that's where like
the score thresholding is important. You're right, you might not get the
most relevant results, uh, if
you have just a subset of the vectors in
inside your, your Valy,
uh, cash and the rest in the.
Durable storage,
uh, but they might be good enough, um,
it works, I think, best if you have the
entirety in here because then you can get the most relevant
results and that's what we see a lot of customers
doing is, um, storing all of their,
their vector data in here. It's just that you have to handle
the, the, the ephemeral nature of it when
you do that.
OK, thank you.
Cool.
Thank you, and I'll take other questions, uh,
offline, uh,
that will be around outside. Thank you so much.